as a speaker you are from the moment you
leave your house you theoretically could
be on I know speakers who have like oh I
got on the plane and the person I was
sitting next to was the VP that hired me
for this event and so now we have the
entire flight where I've technically got
to be on or I get to the hotel and I'm
just walking in after a long day of
travel and yet people see me and they're
like oh I think that's the keynote
speaker and so if I'm rude to staff or
if I'm disheveled Etc then it's like all
that comes on from the moment I walk in
the door I'm on in some ways I think
that helped limit the self talk because
it's like okay I've got this mental
checklist of the things that I need to
do being ready the second you walk out
of your house is something that I've put
more weight in because it goes for
anything it goes for comedy shows that's
where it came up to me first where
you're hanging out at a show or you're
hanging out at a club and they're like
oh this comic didn't show up we need you
to go on and it's like you got to be
ready you got to know your material you
got to know your stuff that well that if
you're going to be in those environments
you got to be ready to go I think it all
comes down to preparation at some level
cuz you put in the work and that's
really all you can do